[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de ciron par les sports
si vous ne connaissez pas encore le
concept vous allez tomber amoureux de
cette émission ce talk et pour les
passionnés de sport local et de sport
yvelinois aujourd'hui au programme comme
toujours une dose de bonne humeur des
analyses sportives et surtout des coups
de gueule et des à débat nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous en plateau
ou via écran interposé pour s'exprimer
sur cette actualité sportive évinoise à
présentation musique commence il suit
par un homme qui compte dans le paysage
sportif illinois est une nouvelle fois
présent sur cette édition et connaît
tout sur tout c'est une véritable
encyclopédie à l'italienne lovers
grégory canal et avec bonjour michael
bonjour à toutes et à tous
comment allez vous aimez écouter très
bien le sport se dé confirme petit à
petit il ya l'euro de foot qui arrive
bientôt
avec e on et on l'espère aussi un été
avec le soleil au rendez vous donc dire
que le moral est au beau fixe
si le soleil n'est pas encore là
malheureusement on espère on espère
qu'il va revenir on continue par un
monument de cette émission musicale sur
la route pour rentrer à dans les
yvelines et tenez absolument à être avec
nous
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable pilier de
cette émission il nous vient tout droit
du rugby-club de via de versailles
pierre chevallier est avec nous pendant
une heure une forme et bonheur à tous
salut salut effectivement d'arrêt de
peur on n'arrête pas la technique et on
arrive même à se connecter à distance
distance
on est d'accord ce n'est pas un fond
vert derrière vous c'est pas vous qui
conduisait un voilà c'est très bien
aussi le souligner c'est ce alors un
rugbyman peut en cacher un autre une
autre personnalité avec nous dans cette
émission musique c'est un coach qui n'a
pas sa langue dans sa poche
il a un avis sur tout et attention il
est en très grande forme aujourd'hui
attention aux plaquages genlis ex-coach
de plaisir est avec nous pendant une
heure bonjour les calais bonjour à tous
bonjour genre comment allez-vous pleine
forme tout le mond pleine forme
alors aujourd'hui c'est l'ouverture des
terrasses ah oui mais bon le tailler
paraît quand même hein donc
malheureusement je tiens à préciser vous
auriez pu être en terrasse vous avez
préféré être avec nous un pendant une
heure mais tout à fait tout à fait j'ai
pas jeu parfait de terrassa midi parfait
alors on va terminer par une petite
nouvelle musique c'est une trappistes
elle a 22 ans elle fait du golf au
niveau amateur depuis six ans vous
l'avez sûrement vu sur les nombreux
golfs libinois c'est également une
blogueuse et une influence sur le golf
féminin j'en suis
que vous allez l'adorer manie la langue
sanaa sera également avec nous pendant
une heure comment allez-vous et aux
batteries et toi ouais très très bien
alors comment comment vous sentez vous
pour votre grande première voix super en
pleine forme en pleine forme alors vous
êtes spécialisés plutôt dans le golf
féminin je tiens à préciser
tessa tu fais la promotion du golf
féminin des puits à 203 ans et j'ai un
blog dans ce cas là pour et sur des
articles et et voilà qui s'appelle
rapidement les dates acteurs termina
voilà si vous voulez aller voir en tout
cas le golf au féminin avant de passer
au programme de l'émission nous allons
parler à 2 à baseball les cougars de
monti le bretonneux reprendront le
championnat de première division le 13
juin prochain contre l'équipe de roy une
bonne nouvelle pour le club qui n'a pas
pu jouer en compétition depuis de longs
mois et qui pense et ne pas pouvoir
jouer cette saison l'écoutent la
réaction du directeur technique du club
il en parle tout le temps ça fait depuis
six mois qu'on en parle qu'on n'arrête
pas d'en parler avec voilà la patience
et aussi certaines incertitudes parce
que voilà un qu'on y duclos vide
on n'était pas sûr qu'ils allaient avoir
un championnat parce que l'année
dernière ça a été annulé
donc voilà c'est c'était compliqué pour
eux aussi voilà d'attendre et puis là on
sait qu'on va reprendre donc le 12 juin
contre ronde
alors est-ce qu'il fallait le reprendre
malgré tout même en décalé grégory tout
d'abord je pense que oui puisque la
saison dernière le championnat de
baseball n'avait pas eu lieu donc c'est
important je pense qu'il n'y ait pas
deuxième année sans sens une saison de
d1 de baseball maintenant le petit bémol
que je mettrais c'est que ça reprend
donc le 13 juin contre rouen on sait que
le sport de contact sera autorisé
seulement qu' à partir du 9 juin pour le
sport en extérieur
donc ils auront très peu de temps pour
se préparer on va dire dans les
conditions les conditions réelles pour
reprendre face à rouen qui en plus à un
gros morceau
rouen puisque c'est à l'équipe qui a
gagné les cinq derniers championnats de
d1 en baseball il avait affronté
d'ailleurs rouen en finale c'était en
2018 je crois et c'est une défaite pour
demander unis donc bien sûr très heureux
que ça puisse reprendre avec ce petit
bémol ils ont pas on va dire toutes les
semaines et tous les jours nécessaires
pour se préparer on va dire dans des
conditions normales manila qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
on ne vous entend pas il faut réactiver
votre micro on va y arriver
et voilà c'est bon je pense que c'est on
l'attend impatiemment le retour à des
compétitions des amateurs
donc quoi qu'il arrive il fallait
reprendre oui il faut les reprendre ces
savants fins important je pense enfin
finalement pour aller pour les amateurs
même ça c'est le sport c'est un prix tu
as donc je pense que ça fait pas mal
pour bad heureux de reprendre la vie un
peu at il pire chevalier est ce que
c'est important également pour les les
partenaires aussi deux de ses clubs on
sait que c'est une équipe qui joue en
première division donc il ya forcément
des partenaires qui sont derrière est-ce
que c'était important de reprendre
également pour eux c'est primordial à la
fois pour les pour les partenaires pour
les licenciés pour les joueurs eux mêmes
c'est même surprenant qu'un sport comme
le baseball soit considérée comme sport
de contact et donc c'est comme ça je
pense pas que ça soit un des sports on
se croise le plus où justement il est
vraiment des contacts à part de balle et
bat et gants mais à part ça c'est c'est
curieux mais c'est comme ça pour les
partenaires oui il ya une errements qui
est un déficit de visibilité qui qui
dure depuis maintenant 18 mois et dans
tous les sports et notamment amateurs
qui le gif que par les dix ans s'est
parlé et parlé soutien des sponsors
c'est indispensable qu'on puisse même
sur une courte période pouvoir pouvoir
voir un bout de saison et à bout de
visibilité surtout pouvoir échanger
autour du sport année là on parle et
c'est primordial pour les valeurs pour
le bien-être pour pour le chic et pour
les affaires pour les affaires des
partenaires effective gens ils n'ont pas
joué depuis deux ans la saison dernière
c'était une saison blanche cette année
et reprennent
en juin est-ce que ça va jouer aussi
dans la préparation de l'équipe est ce
que ça va être dur la reprise tout
simplement
et forcément forcément la reprise sera
dur mais elle sera dure pour tout le
monde puisque tout le monde est dans le
même cas de figure ils ne sont pas
exempts veut il n'ya pas qu'eux qui n'a
pas joué donc mais même leur adversaire
direct qui est qu'ils soient rouen sera
dans les mêmes conditions
simplement greg la halle à souligner
tout à l'heure ils auront très très peu
de temps pour se préparer ils n'auront
même pas de rencontre amicale ils
n'auront pas le temps mais quelque part
c'est un avantage de jouer une grosse
pointure d'entrée je ne pense pas je ne
connais pas leur marche à suivre est
sportive
je ne pense pas qu'ils avaient misé sur
une victoire à tout prix contre un des
favoris donc mais faire ce premier match
dans lequel ils ont avec lequel j'ai pas
trop de préparation mais leur fera du
bien leur fera une très très bonne
préparation pour pouvoir après être
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus performant
sur les autres compétitions fait sur les
autres
les hordes d'adversaires grigori sur cet
aspect là je suis plutôt d'accord avec
jean sur le fait que ce soit peut-être
le meilleur moment pour pour montigny
d'affronter rouen qui elle aussi cette
équipe de rouen même si c'est une grande
équipe de baseball en france n'aura pas
les temps de préparation nécessaire mais
comme toutes les autres équipes
après ils n'arriveront pas à préparer et
effectivement ils pourront pas forcément
jouer deux rencontres amicales mais on
sait que le sport dans une pratique sans
contact était autorisée donc
physiquement j'ose espérer qu'ils
arriveront en forme après c'est vrai que
la vérité c'est les rencontres et à ce
sens ils n'ont pas forcément dire de
motifs valables pour se préparer il n'y
aura pas de rencontre amicale donc c'est
vraiment aussi ça c'est la réalité des
rencontres qui font aussi qu'on est
performant après dans les compétitions
fameuse vérité du terrain quand comme on
dit dans le jargon
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler un football trappistes
françois mendy vient de signer son tout
premier contrat professionnel avec le
club de châteauroux coup de projecteur
également sur l'annulation sur les
critiques 2 arthur enoch nage vis-à-vis
du gel du classement atp mais avant de
développer ces thèmes on va parler golfe
[Musique]
on va donc parler golf seul français
présent sur le circuit américain la
semaine du 10 mai antoine ros meneur n'a
pas brillé pour sa grande première sur
le pid j ai tour le pensionnaire du golf
de la boulie à versailles n'a pas passé
le cut avec un score total de -5 le 70e
mondiale a raté la qualification pour le
week end pour un seul coup libinois aura
l'occasion de se rattraper cette semaine
il participera à son premier majeur us
fidji en caroline du sud avant d'aller
début juin sur le mémorial tournament en
tout cas antoine or other était heureux
était heureuse de s'envoler pour les
états unis nous l'avons eue en interview
au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines juste avant
son départ pour les usa ont les gouttes
très très heureux moi c'est un rêve de
pouvoir m'installer là-bas et évoluer
sur le circuit américain donc non c'est
une très belle opportunité pour moi et
en tout cas quand il ya ce sera une
super expérience donc non très très
content la question sur cette thématique
cette première peut-elle le faire douter
pour l'avenir une première déception sur
le tour américain parce que ça peut le
faire douter
oui ou non non pour grégory non pour
vous pierre non pour vous également
manila et non pour vous également jean
donc vous êtes tous d'accord
manila je vais vous donner à la parole
vous êtes un peu notre spécialiste golf
avec avec pierre chevalier qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que ça peut le faire douter cette
première désillusion
cette première sur le circuit
professionnel tu sais j'ai bien compris
circuit professionnel américain
attention c'est oui c'est une grande
étape je pense pour antoine renard et
puis en plus même pour aller français
que ce qu'il en est déjà un joueur
français qui va sur le circuit américain
cdc c'est énorme
si est-ce que ça va le faire douter je
pense que il est préparé pour aller sur
une circuit et la fédé belle saison ces
derniers mois il a eu à ses deux
victoires et fait qu'il ya eu cette idée
mais c'est mérité
après oui ça va le faire un peu tout et
parce que a il sait très bien qui sera
bien entouré avec des meilleurs
professionnels que les meilleurs joueurs
donc ça c'est normal qu'il ait un peu de
thé mais je pense qu'il est préparé pour
ça pierre chevalier
vous êtes notre deuxième spécialiste
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors vous
vous avez dit non tout de suite
moi j'ai dit j'ai dit non tout de suite
parce que je pense qu'il faut il faut
bien distinguer distinguer le passé de
l'avenir ce qui est très très notable
sur le parcours d'antoine depuis six
mois
c'est justement les différents les
différents tournois sur lesquelles il
s'est aligné
et ces victoires là depuis six mois en
fin d'année 2020 il gagne et gagne à
dubaï mars 2021 et gagne au qatar en
championnat du monde de match-play il
pas paris sonne de chambre il est le
héros idée pleine bourre depuis depuis
six mois et la loupe et le cut d'un
premier tournoi sur le circuit américain
d'un d'un coup n'est pas népal chose
n'est pas chose facile pour enrayer en
fait sa bonne série
las il faut voir aussi c'est que dans le
futur proche
il va s'aligner sur lui et sans pitié et
sur deux tournois aux états unis où il
va pouvoir un petit peu fait rallier ou
et pouvoir se monte en puissance mais
mais c'est pas parce qu'il rate le cut
d'un coup sûr le sur le byron qu'il va
pour autant douter à la fois de ses
capacités de ses forces
puisque vraiment là ce qui a étonné
c'est que il sort pas du bois
depuis depuis depuis longue date mais il
est il est préparé et il est pour avoir
pour un joueur qui n'était pas forcément
destiné au golfe au début c'est un hutu
meilleur espoir et c'est justement une
expérience le fait de rater d'une marche
d'un coup le coeur de ce tournoi là ça
va l'ouvrir et ça va le préparer aux
trois prochains je tiens à préciser que
vous êtes dans la voiture avec le
directeur du golf de la boulie à à
versailles dont vous ne pouvez pas dire
de méchants chaussures en toile rosner
tout est surveillé exactement je suis
avec donc jean franck bureaux le 2 le
directeur de du racing club de france de
l'éboulis dans air force one parce que
c'est notre nouveau président de la dgf
aussi de l'association des directeurs de
gaulle de france et donc la boulie c'est
le club le club initiale de danton de
rance nerfs de toute la famille hausner
une famille doria sigman historique jean
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
du coup d'antoine runner de cette
première désillusion pour lui sur le
circuit américain
je rappelle qu'il est jeune il a 28 ans
oui mais voilà qu'hier l'a dit c'est une
contre performance de médoc où il rate
le cut d'un coup un coup c'est rien du
tout ou rien du tout ils états unis et
il est né d'une belle progression il on
l'a rappelé après ses deux victoires au
qatar et à dubaï
donc c'est simplement une contre
performance comme tous les sportifs dans
toutes les disciplines et
malheureusement il passe le jour là elle
se fera ni la première ni la dernière
mais ça ne remet pas alors aucunement en
cause son parcours actuel et sa
progression actuelle parce que ce il
faut il faut à travers des défaites
aussi grandir et apprendre et ça va lui
faire le plus grand bien pour moi parce
que justement il était peut-être un
petit peu trop peut-être intrigue mais
je ne sais pas dans un petit peu trop
sûr de lui
ça leur fait un petit peu des starter
l'euro motiver leurs cons ça me plaît et
ne pas refaire les mêmes erreurs donc
une défaite c'est pas en remettant en
question tout tout un programme et toute
une année
une progression sur une sur le couac on
prend forme assure tout d'un coup c'est
impeccable qui continue comme ça et je
parle c'est qu'il va venir en bondir
grigoris qu'il fallait pas quand même
qui marque le coup ainsi anciens on peut
dire dès ce premier tournoi américain
il devait pas à performer tout de suite
pour se faire un nom parce que il y à
des grands noms un sursaut retenir les
meilleurs joueurs vendus aux enchères
des grands noms mais ça a été dit il
aura l'occasion bien sûr de se refaire
ya lui est figé et tours
il ya également ce tournoi ton à malte
le mémorial tournament qui arrivent en
début janvier
s'il joue en ce moment donc il aura des
chances de surfer moi je pense que ça
aurait pu mettre une pression
supplémentaire qui fasse tout de suite
qui brille tout de suite pour sa
première sur le circuit américain
justement serait plus trop le met sous
le feu des projecteurs et peut-être le
griller pour la suite je vais pas
apprendre les choses agent qui est
entraîneur cédant aussi dans la défaite
qu'on apprend et qu'on apprend de ses
erreurs pour pour progresser moi je
pense que c'était peut-être le meilleur
moment pour avoir un revers voilà sa
première il a ce revers et ça supprime
est vraiment pas du tout ses dernières
performances où il a émergé très
récemment sur la scène du golf mondial
avec ce titre de meilleur joueur issu du
challenge tour la saison dernière ces
deux tournois remportés
non moi je pense que ça va l'aider à se
remettre en question peut-être le faire
douter dans la façon dont on va dire
d'appréhender les prochains tournois
mais pas tout et sur ses capacités moi
j'y crois pas parce que sur les
dernières semaines sur les derniers mois
il a quand même pas mal briller il a
emporté aussi le linxea ff golf aussi
juste avant de s'envoler pour les états
unis s'apprêtent à jouer dans sa
préparation aussi un pierre chevalier
est-ce qu'il faut ajouter c'est que
c'est que la visibilité dont vous
parliez sur le circuit américain et
auprès des américains il l'a gagné il
l'a gagnée lors du championnat du monde
de match-play cantine et quand il a
réussi à battre au premier tour par les
scènes de chambre au un ils n'étaient
pas attendus plutôt le petit frenchy
qu'on ne connaissait pas encore
et il a acquis déjà une première partie
d'être de noblesse sur c'est sur cette
compétition en match play dont il ya en
un contre un et en battant un des tout
meilleurs joueurs américains donc
il a déjà attiré un petit peu le
projecteur sur lui je suis assez
d'accord avec greg sur la partie la
partie pression le fait le fait de ne
pas démarrer tambour bâton sur le
premier tournoi des premiers tournois ça
peut peut-être lui enlever une partie
d'une partie de pression sur le tournoi
qui est en train de jouer actuellement
et chaumié ce budget qui est le premier
majeur
enfin à des majeurs de la saison
justement est-ce qu'il n'a pas mis la
barre peut-être un petit peu trop haute
avec une victoire contre brighton de
chambaud le numéro 5 mondial a man il a
peut-être qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce qu'il n'a pas mis la barre déjà
trop haute et forcément on en attend
beaucoup de lui maintenant les médias en
attendent beaucoup
je pense que la première que j'ai si je
pensais qu'il faut les gagner et je
pense c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il a
qu'il a peut-être raté une partie de son
jeu mais en tout cas
en tout cas je pense qu'il a il a fait
des d'après d'après les interviews il
semblerait qu'il a cédé vos choix avec
son caddie et oui je pense que il a joué
son jeu et après c'est lutter c'est
juste une expérience jean dernière
question il a fait je le disais le
tournoi ffgolf linxea juste avant de
partir au golf national il est parti un
petit peu tard sur les états unis dans
sa préparation ce que ça a pu jouer
il arrivait finalement le dimanche je
crois dimanche matin à dimanche soir ou
lundi matin
est-ce que ça a pu jouer ou pas dans sa
préparation de cette tournée américaine
non non je ne passe pas je pense que
c'était prévu la préparation il sait pas
rajouté au dernier moment une
compétition et un tournoi dans sa doit
être prévu le pass je pense plutôt que
par rapport à cette première échéance
américaine il avait peut-être aussi une
pression qu'il n'avait pas juste avant
donc testé différentes prestations ya
plus qu il a pu faire à dubaï et au
qatar où là il n'était pas trois tenues
et puis contre comme l'a dit pierre
votre l'américain mais là il était
plutôt attendu donc là ils étaient ils
étaient challenger le plat il n'y a pas
de problème l'acte
une pression supplémentaire qu'ils
n'avaient pas jusqu'à présent c'était
aussi ça explique aussi le le pourquoi
du comment est ce ce petit à petit col
rond performance d'un coup en tout cas
le client s'est dit ouais il était censé
jouer comme tous les autres français ont
été 1 il était censé jouer le pote de
france somme qui aurait dû se jouer
début mai et donc c'est ce qu'il ya
aussi un petit peu perturbé l'agenda
alors continuons évidemment suivre
antoine ros nord sur tb 78 dans les
prochains mois on en espère le voir
triompher pourquoi pas à lui est speed
gdd cette semaine alors voir maintenant
parler football l'ancien trappistes
françois mendy aujourd'hui âgé de 21 ans
vient de signer son tout premier contrat
professionnel il a assigné avec le club
de châteauroux qui évolué cette année en
ligue 2 et qui descendra l'année
prochaine en national levy noah est
arrivé au club il ya trois ans en
provenance de l'étoile sportive de
trappes il était invité dans le à 7,8
sport de ce 17 mai il nous parle de ses
objectifs
mes objectifs était de jouer un max de
temps de jeu au max et franchement
apporter un plus à cette équipe est de
remonter en ligue 2 la question sur ce
thème
est-ce qu'il peut exploser au plus haut
niveau oui ou non il a 21 ans et il
vient de signer son premier contrat
professionnel il est en ligue 2 pour
l'instant mais châteauroux va descendre
en national est-ce qu'il peut exploser
au plus haut niveau
oui ou non moins mitigé pour vous
grégory mitigé pour vous êtes tous
mitigé en fait sur sur cette question
alors je vais donner la parole à amman
il a peut-être avant de passer la parole
aux autres manila qu'est ce que vous en
pensez tout simplement de cette
signature
je pense je suis un peu mitigé aussi
mais bon après je suis content qu'il ya
un trappistes qui est qu'ils ont les
deux c'est génial
est ce que est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut percer au plus haut niveau
votre avis est ce que ça peut ça peut le
faire pour lui ou pas du tout je pense
que oui wayne allwine ça va dépendre
vraiment à l'aise l'entraînement je
pense que moi je crois vraiment talent
des jeunes et des nouveaux locaux au
niveau sportif donc je pense que oui je
pense que oui si sera qu'un ses preuves
et c'est gros et vous qui est un peu
notre spécialiste football pour le coup
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
bien sûr alors vous êtes très mauvais
pronostic il faut le rappeler mais
est on attend réussir une belle carrière
mais c'est possible c'est tout à fait
possible
pourquoi moi je suis mitigé je crois
qu'il peut exploser effectivement au
plus haut niveau mais attention les
grands espoirs du football on en a connu
mais des paquets donc j'ai pas envie
trop de le mettre sur le devant de la
scène j'ai envie qu'il travaille et
c'est aussi le voilà le message que
cherche à faire passer que j'ai déjà
fait passer dans ses émissions
laissons les jeunes travailler
tranquille ne le mettrons pas trop sur
le devant de la scène
ce qui est bien c'est que l'année
prochaine châteauroux évoluera en
national là cette année en ligue 2 tête
que la marche est un peu trop et il a il
a été appelé à trois reprises par marco
simone elle avait des bouts de match
j'ai beau match il a surtout joué en
réserve en nationale 3 où il a marqué il
a marqué 8 buts donc c'est pas mal et
puis ça qui sèchent match mais pour un
attaquant voilà c'est pas mal là ce qui
est bien c'est quand dans le championnat
national qui est peut-être moins exposée
que la ligue 1 et la ligue 2 il aura
l'occasion de démarrer
on va dire sans être sous le feu des
projecteurs et de continuer sa
progression tranquillement donc c'est
pour ça que je suis mitigé bien sûr que
j'y crois et où j'ai envie d'y croire
j'ai envie qu'un trappistes
effectivement qu'un yvelinois puisse
briller du côté de châteauroux et
peut-être un jour espérer soit alors
peut-être une remontée en ligue 2 mais
peut-être un jour le voir jouer en ligue
1 mais laissons le travailler tranquille
là il a une saison en national il aura
sûrement un peu plus de temps de jeu
pour progresser tranquillement genre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors vous est mitigée également oui
alors je suis dit j'ai bon déjà j'espère
qu'il a plus de gaz sur le terrain que
lors de l'interview il va il va
s'endormir
essilor j'ai parlé tous les matchs
françois mendy je peux pas vous
confirmer mais sinon alors j'étais
mitigé pourquoi parce que ben je suis vu
comme greg en a parlé plusieurs fois sur
le plateau les sols les jeunes
travailler et devenir des grands parce
que des grands espoirs a commis beaucoup
l'ogc nice où blake il peut pas se
cacher jean il peut plus cacher alors
d'accord ok il peut plus se cacher je
suis d'accord maintenant là où je suis
mitigé
c'est qu'il n'a pas signer dans un grand
club de ligue 2 il a signé un club qui
des singes train de la ligue 2 pour
rejoindre aston a donc déjà bon il a 21
ans il est pas mieux mais il n'est pas
tout jeune non plus donc il est il et
puis la ligue 2
nationale a donc le temps plein n'est
pas le même quand même il aurait signé
un club obtient mais de ligue 2 on est
là pour l'instant il n'est pas titulaire
il y avait un club qui descend donc le
chemin est encore long pour devenir un
grand joueur
donc les soldes travail et c'est pour ça
que je suis mitigé le pilat il a
certainement voilà comme beaucoup
beaucoup
si un sport qui draine énormément de
joueurs avec un patrick y en a très peu
mais elles sortent c'est bien le
football donc je sais pour chose c'est
très drôle là que j'étais mitigé sur le
fait que ce soit le futur graves
brûlures pierre chevallier il a donc 21
ans 1 m 78 pour 69 kg il est attaquant
on a on a souvent le même avis avec jean
et greg sur le justement c'était cette
nécessité de laisser laisser mûrir les
jeunes talents plus aussi jeune que ça
comme le dit jean a vanté un nom mais on
a on a on a cette chance d'avoir pris il
ya des joueurs qui arrivent tard dans le
football certes il y en a peu mais il y
en a quelques-uns on peut prendre
l'exemple de mathieu valbuena par
exemple qui joue en national qui a joué
à l'olympique de marseille y en a
d'autres il ya il ya plein d'exemples
comme ça donc finalement il peut avoir
sa chance
e
pierre chevalier je crois qu'on l'a
perdu
toujours donné à marolles gens ou sans
oublier intéressés par la question
il ne souhaite qu elle laisse ou d'un
tunnel seront groupés on la récupère le
calme trop tôt pour le trop tôt pour le
dire
c'est là où on a c'est là où on a
peut-être l'occasion de le voir on l'a
perdue pour le moment british vous en
pensez vous moi ce que je que je
souhaite ajouter voilà prêt à laisser
récupérer là donc c'est vrai que bon 21
ans si on compare aux derniers grands
français qu'il ya des maps et qui a
émergé très tôt c'est sûr que 21 ans ça
peut paraître âgées mais vous le disiez
michael je pense que il peut aussi
éclore plus tard il ya des joueurs
justement qui font leur éclosion plutôt
sur sur la fin sur passé les 25 ans donc
ça c'est tout à fait possible moi ce que
je souhaite souligner est que ce que je
voulais souligner pardon ce que je
souhaitais souligné je vais y arriver
c'est que ce qui est pas mal c'est aussi
la formation trappistes qu'on peut
mettre en avant avec des joueurs qui
sortent de trappes
il ya effectivement françois mendy qui
vient de signer son premier contrat
professionnel mettra pneus n'en est pas
alors ils sont pas à leur coup d'essai
du côté des trappistes il ya eu chaque
belfodil aussi qu'à une belle carrière
du côté de l'italie qui a été formé à
l'olympique lyonnais qui est passé par
line terre par parme en italie
forcément on pense aussi à nicolas
anelka en finale il joue à hoffenheim a
aujourd'hui on pense forcément aussi à
nicolas anelka à walid mesloub aussi
dont on a parlé
la dernière fois dans le sop donc ce
qu'il faut souligner aussi c'est que tu
rattrape travaille très bien et fait
émerger régulièrement aussi des joueurs
qui qui signent des contrats
professionnels pierre on vous a récupéré
on ne vous entendez pas sur votre
réponse
qu'est ce que vous vouliez dire et là
vous avez coupé votre micro pierre
couper le micro
voilà on y arrive
non non je disais qu'il a 21 ans il est
sans doute trop tôt pour le dire qu'il
va exploser au plus haut niveau mais je
disais aussi que cette expérience d'une
descente
arrivé dans un club qui descend pour
pouvoir le faire remonter en ligue 2 ça
c'est l'expérience qui va pourra le
faire mûrir et c'est sûrement censure ce
type d'expérience là qu'il va pouvoir se
faire un nom si les participer s'il a du
temps de jeu on va continuer cette
émission par du basket le mercato
français risque d'être agitée dans les
prochaines semaines et un heavy noah
pourrait être l'un des joueurs les plus
demandés son nom victor webb anyama le
sportif de 17 ans passé notamment par le
club du chesnay versailles est
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui à nanterre
pourrait voir sa carrière monte d'un
cran il pourrait atterrir à l'asvel l'un
des clubs phares en france ce sportif de
deux mètres 19 pour est arrivé cet été
pour une seule saison avant de s'envoler
pour les états unis à l'occasion de la
draft 2022
cette rumeur pourrait se concrétiser
dans les prochaines semaines la question
victor wanyama doit-il quitter nanterre
voté oui ou non
est-ce qu'il doit quitter nanterre pour
aller à l'asvel oui pour vous oui pour
vous on fait un petit duel entre jean et
grégory qui et qui dit non lui par
contre grégory et vous commencez oui
alors la parole à jean je ne sais pas
s'il doit quitter je pense que ça
pourrait être un bon choix de cas alors
pourquoi je me suis positionné content
parce que à nanterre et commence à
s'imposer il est régulièrement
maintenant dans le cinq majeur de
donnadieu son son coach donc il commence
à s'imposer à nanterre il commence à
faire vraiment des grosses prestations à
chaque fois qu'ils aient que son coach
fait appel à lui fait des grosses
prestations ces statistiques très
rapidement 6 5 points par match 5,1
rebonds et cinq contres en 15 minutes de
moyenne
ceci qui est qu'ils jouent à nanterre
donc il commence à s'imposer dans le
cinq majeur de l'équipe à nanterre on
rappelle qu'en début de saison
était plutôt avec la réserve il jouait
de temps en temps notamment en coupe
d'europe avec avec tentèrent donc moi je
pense que il doit rester à nanterre
avant peut-être de s'envoler vers les
états unis pour s'affirmer comme un
joueur on va dire important de nanterre
est un joueur important de la proa moi
ce qui me fait peur s'il part à l'asvel
qui est l'un des gros clubs français qui
est l'un des clubs les plus titrés en
france qui est d'ailleurs le dernier
tenant du titre puisque la saison
dernière le championnat avait été arrêté
je pense que peut-être la marche serait
peut-être un peu trop tes ce qui va pas
griller juste avant de viser son
objectif américain parce qu'on parle de
lui à la draft 2022 plutôt 2023 mais ça
pourrait être 2022 moi j'ai peur que la
marche soit trop haute
après ce qui me fait douter ce qui me
fait douter et j'ai peut-être donner un
élément de réponse pour pour gens
dansent dans ce duel c'est qu'il ya tony
parker du côté de l'asvel et avoir quand
même tony parker à côté lui ça pour être
quand même quelque chose quelque chose
de bien mais je reste fixé sur mon idée
qu'il doit rester à nanterre pour
devenir un grand de la pro a et je pense
que à nanterre il en a les moyens
je suis moins convaincu du côté de
l'asvel gens qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
alors vous allez reprendre vraiment tony
parker oui même la souplesse et il a dû
se dire mais j'avais oublié sa vraie vie
ça la met l'autre et j'avais oublié
non mais c'est vrai mais je me servirai
pas pourvoi la nuit là je l'espère
voilà je suis fair play temps pour moi
pour moi pour moi c'était celle tremplin
avant avant de partir pour une grande
expérience américaine
il est effectivement bien inscrit à
nanterre il compte 10 commence à avoir
une grande évolution avoir des belles
statistiques et pour moi allez les
engueuler comme l'asvel juste pour déjà
changé de club être naître plus dans le
confort parce que finalement quand on
reste dans le même club
quand même un certain confort on est un
petit peu la vedette confort c'est pour
ça vous restez à gif-sur-yvette vous
comme coach
oui je suis à gif-sur-yvette je suis je
suis très très bien c'est un super club
c'est un lieu magnifique conte wisdom et
non mais c'est celle que ça et le fait
de le redescendre légèrement d'un cran à
l'aider
grand club français avant de partir
faire son expérience aux états unis et
mais pour moi c'est un bon complet parce
que il sera peut-être pas il sera
peut-être pas d'histoire il ne va pas
être là le grand favori du groupe à la
semaine et il va redescendre un petit
peu d'un à sa place on va dire et pour
moi ça fait est unique c'est un
excellent est un excellent tremplin
et puis bien sûr il ay là il aura à ses
côtés un petit parker que l'expérience
qu'on lui connaît et qui pourra qui
pourra le lui apporter tout le tout tout
tout le positif dont il a besoin pour
pouvoir s envoler dans le système
américain
vous aviez vous n'alliez pas l'utiliser
en gens vous l'avez utilisé comme on
l'avait glissé à la fin l'asvel il
allait quand même avoir l'appui d'un
gars comme tony parker avec la carrière
qu'on lui connaît manila qu'est ce que
vous en pensez qui vous a convaincu
est-ce que c'est grégory qui veut que
webm anyama reste à nanterre ou plutôt
gens qui préfèrent l'envoyer dans la
région lyonnaise et pu l'avoir à côté
d'eux des yvelines ah ben je bien sûr je
suis complètement d'accord avec ce qu'il
dit l'asvel c'est un jeu connaît pas
vraiment le milieu du basket mais en
tout cas à l'asvel c'est un superbe
centre d'entraînement il ya
l'ambassadeur tony parker qui va super
bien entraîné tout le voir et ça va lui
donner beaucoup plus de challenge et ça
va lui effectivement le sortir de sa
zone de confort parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on avance et oui voilà il va pouvoir
rencontrer d'autres acteurs et après il
sera bien préparé pour partir
hélène guillou ça c'est vraiment avec
des plus gros joie est effectivement
avec ace qui est ce qui n'est pas trop
jeunes maniaient a quand même 17 ans
parce qu'il ya trop jeune et maintenant
c'est maintenant ouais c'est maintenant
qu'il faut forger le vois je trouve que
c'est comme ça enfin j'ai beaucoup de
personnes je connais qui sont
année qui vont évoluer dans le
professionnel et 17 ans c'est parfait je
pense faire très rapidement vous vient
rajouter quelque chose non juste pour
dire il est très suivi par on va dire
les influenceurs américain et j'ai mois
la crainte que j'ai c'est siva l'asvel
et qu'ils se trompent complètement qui
ne joue pas sa cote va baisser largement
et à la draft bas ce sera ce sera râpé
pour lui donc pourquoi pourquoi ce m
pourquoi se mettre en danger alors qu'il
peut s'imposer du côté de nanterre est
vraiment devenir un joueur majeur de
l'effectif ce qu'il est en train de
devenir du côté de nanterre genre juste
pour répondre à grégory s'ils n'y
arrivent pas à l'asvel c'est que
finalement ça ne sert à rien entre
guillemets qui lie aux états unis parce
que ça veut dire qu'il n'aura pas encore
le niveau
ça passe par un grand club comme ça pour
moi pour pour moi voilà s'ils s'imposent
à l'asvel
il est prêt pour aller aux états unis et
il fera une grande bleue rien donc ne
laissons pas le temps aux jeunes gens si
j'ai bien compris le message
pierre chevalier ben alors là lors lui
propose de classer une évolution l'année
vous à julien chevalier justement c'est
une et c'est une étape importante
d'aller dans un grand club français sous
la question avait été est-ce qu'il faut
qu'il ait tout de suite en nba on aurait
tous répondu non je pense là c'est c'est
l'étape rêvée pour aller dans un club
structuré professionnels en vue
justement pour préparer son enrôlement
aimiez les singes
c'est un club qui joue la coupe d'europe
également des gros matches de série a
serait plus est une autre étape s'il
avait été approché par un grand club
européen en espagne en grèce ou en
turquie par exemple là ça aurait
peut-être été un poteau line sur le sur
le sol français avec en plus un
spécialiste de la nba est le talon de
qu'on connaît à un tony parker
ça va être parfait pour le préparer pour
son futur en vol alors pour rappeler
quand même ce joueur victor webb anyama
joue vraiment en club depuis deux mois
tout de suite il ya eu des reportages
sur lui en france bien sûr mais
également aux états unis là on parle
d'un gros transferts seulement après
deux mois de compétition et ensuite
peut-être d'une draft en 2022 aux états
unis ce que ça va pas trop vite quand
même
1 pour un jeune de 17 ans ça va super
vite c'est pour ça que moi je reste fixé
sur mon idée qu'il doit d'abord
s'imposer définitivement à nanterre ce
qui n'est pas encore le cas
il a joué début de saison et vous faites
très bien de le rappeler
michael où il débutait plutôt en équipe
réserve il aidé de temps en temps à
appeler par pascal donnadieu avec
l'équipe à
là il commence à faire des matches comme
titulaire il s'impose petit à petit dans
le cinq majeur moi je pense que c'est
trop tôt on disait tout à l'heure
laissons les jeunes travailler
tranquille je suis désolé gens là on
n'est pas dans cette idée là il faut
qu'il travaille tranquillement du côté
de nanterre à nanterre s'est certes pas
le top clubs français l'asvel avec ses
19 titres c'est vrai que c'est une
marche supplémentaire mais nanterre
c'est quand même un club sérieux et un
club connu en berne depuis excusé pour
cette année son 10e je crois en toi
oui ils se maintiendront en première
division cette année donc pourquoi pas
on parle de la 2022 la draft mais ça
sera sûrement celle 2023 si la nba ne
change pas les règles donc pourquoi pas
rester une saison supplémentaire à
nanterre et peut-être s'il ne peut pas
aller à la drave 2022 et à la 2023 là il
pourra faire cette petite marche
supplémentaire du côté de l'asvel mais
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'il reste du
côté de l'asvel parce que c'est là qui
peut grandir tranquillement sans être
trop sous le feu des projecteurs encore
je le répète les sondages rapidement à
passer une autre thématique
alors il a dit l'asvel il a il a même
pas dylan t elle il faut qu'il reste à
l'asvel
j'ai dit l'asvel je soutiens ce
commentaire voilà de lui il est persuadé
bon vous allez vous faire une terrasse
après l'émission on sait comment ça va
se terminer
alors on va passer maintenant notre page
débats
[Musique]
alors dans cette page débats je vais
vous passez la parole la parole à
grégory qu'à l'aller pour son envolée le
moment que tout le monde attend à chaque
émission ne zappez surtout pas c'est le
moment que les français attendent c'est
avoue grégory n'ayez pas la pression
c'est à vous met un peu la pression va
je parle plus aujourd'hui de tennis
michael et d'un sujet qui fait
énormément débat dans le monde de la
petite balle jaune le gel du classement
atp
c'est un système qui a été décidé il ya
un an suite à l'arrêt du circuit entre
mars et août 2020 avec la pandémie de
kobe de 19 ans claire des points gelé un
classement figé pour protéger les
joueuses et les joueurs qui ne
souhaitait pas ou tout simplement ne
pouvait pas se déplacer hors de leurs
frontières pour disputer des tournois
un système qui reste encore aujourd'hui
en partie en vigueur et qui profitent
encore à certains est-ce que ce qu'a
dénoncé lives in war tueur rinderknecht
125e mondial dans une interview au
journal l'équipe dont je vais vous
parler dans un instant oui aujourd'hui
le gel des points est toujours actif il
fonctionne partiellement l atp a décidé
en fait d'un dégel progressif jusqu'au 9
août 2021 pour prendre en compte les
tournois annulé l'an passé où disputé à
des dates inhabituel et je vous rappelle
que c'était le cas par exemple de roland
garros 1 qui a été disputée à l'automne
mais comment cela fonctionne-t-il
eh bien les points acquis entre mars et
août 2019 qui auraient dû normalement
disparaître un jour rappelle que les
classements atp sont calculés en prenant
compte les réels en compte les résultats
des 52 semaines précédentes
eh bien ces points sont finalement
toujours comptabilisés pour 50% de leur
valeur initiale en cas de moins bonnes
performances en 2021
un exemple très concret avec un joueur
qui profite particulièrement de ce
système benoît paire le français qui a
gagné le tournoi de lyon en 2019 a
conservé cette année 125 des 250 points
de son titre soit l'équivalent d'une
finale ce qui explique que malgré deux
petites victoires sur ses 17 derniers
matchs le français est toujours et bien
à une 36ème place mondiale on peut citer
aussi le cas d'autres français gaël
monfils par exemple une seule victoire
obtenue très récemment au tournoi de
lyon
et ce en 15 mois d'activité et pourtant
il pointe toujours au 15e rang mondial
du classement atp
et puis quelqu'un que j'adore une
légende rodger federer
qui n'a pas joué pendant un an et qui
pour son retour a perdu en quarts de
finale à doha il a également perdu très
récemment au premier tour à genève est
le suisse est malgré tout à une 8e place
mondiale
finalement le système protégé les
joueurs dans le haut du classement et
d'aurélie fille parce que du coup ceux
qui sont derrière et qui frappent à la
porte pour entrer ne serait ce que dans
le top 100 sont désavantagés on en
revient à notre local de l'étape arthur
rinderknecht deux tournois gagnés en
2020 à rennes et calgary 1 à istanbul en
début dé but à 2021 qui était une 54e
place mondiale sur la reille saint jo
précise bien que c'est sur la reille
cela reste c'est un classement différent
de du classement atp c'est un classement
qui prend en compte la saison en cours
et bien le saint germanois se retrouvent
bloqués dans le circuit challenger et ne
peut pas accéder au tableau principal
car empêchés de participer aux meilleurs
tournois mondiaux est sauf quand il
reçoit et bien une invitation et celle
qu'un pour le prochain roland garros il
a reçu une wild-card le joueur de 25 ans
a dénoncé ce système dans le journal
l'équipe
évidemment que c'est un peu gênant quand
on voit pas forcément benoin il ne
citait pas forcément benoît paire mais
que certains joueurs qui ne jouent pas
ou qui n'ont pas une grande motivation
et qui sont sur la fin et qui en profite
pour continuer à aller juste sur les
gros tournois et empocher les gros prize
money on se dit que ça fait des places
perdues at il déclaré au journal en
ajoutant ensuite on m'a dit il n'y a pas
longtemps que sans le gel des
classements je serai autour de la 80e
place mondiale
ce serait génial d'être dans un top 100
maintenant j'espère que ce n'est pas à
cause de cette règle que je n'irai
jamais plus haut dans mon classement
actuel donc peut être que d'accord avec
ces propos même si l'atp a reconnu un
inévitable inévitablement une hausse de
la protection des joueurs qui peut
engendrer un certain immobilisme du
classement pour d'autres alors si
effectivement ce système était
nécessaire j'en suis convaincu au début
avec l'arrêt des tournois je trouve
aberrant qu'il puisse encore fonctionné
aujourd'hui on est on est tombé pas mal
on veut malgré tout sur le football ces
derniers temps mais le tennis est bien
finalement c'est le même sujet
on trouve un que le mérite sportif est
quelque peu bafouée en ce moment est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec grégory est
ce que l'on va dire l'idée principale de
ce classement se gèlent entraîne un
souci pour certains joueurs est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec lui est ce que
ça pose un problème dans ce circuit
international
oui ou non oui pour vous genre oui pour
vous manila et pour vous plaire je crois
que vous êtes figé vous êtes perdus pour
l'instant à vous est aussi d'accord
manila qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est une vraie problématique quand on
est con soit figé par des compétitions
figé pour les professionnels parce que
ils ont passé une mi-temps à s'entraider
ils ont le fait qu'on l'ait arrêté
tu peux vide maljean n'a pas le choix
c'est c'est vraiment une grosse
problématique est ce que vous pensez que
certains profitent de ce système votre
avis comme le pense est un tueur des 9,9
manila pour un jeu passionnant compris
le classement est ce que vous pensez que
certains certains profitent un peu du
système on parle beaucoup de benoît
paire notamment qui gagne peu mais qui
est quand même dans le top 40 mondial
[Applaudissements]
je vais passer la parole à agent du coup
et qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
jean oui ou non mais moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce sportif tout à
fait d'accord avec lui il est il est
anormal
il est anormal que sportif qu'un
tennisman comme lui qui joue et qui
gagne ne puisse pas rester dans le
classement ça pour moi et un costume à
conjurer les autres quand ils ne jouent
pas et qu'on les protège entre
guillemets pourquoi pas moi ça me gêne
pas ça me gêne pas dans la mesure où on
l'est faute qui joue et qui gagne
pouvoir progresser parce que ce client
voilà exactement mais on vous plus on
joue plus ou les rénovations est plus
court
à la meilleure place donc c'est pas bon
à laval le mans a fait normalement et
cartons jaunes ou pas on régresse
hélas et je lui ai donc mais ils
auraient ils auraient dû progresser
ensuite à brest est vrai que dans la
mesure où il ya moins de paris pas moins
de lui beaucoup de joueurs comme pas et
n'ai pas pu jouer que pas voulu jouer
donc sarah ont ce qui peut-être les
tournois en plus facile entre guillemets
et ça c'était ça la vie personnelle ne
pas laisser le personnel mais je reste
sur ce voyage que convaincus que leur
petit jeu lorsqu'on joue et qu'on gagne
on doit être voir etc ont presté ils
auraient dû profiter
est-ce que vous pensez que que par
exemple arthur et nantes neige pour être
dans le top 100 mondial à votre avis
malgré avec ceux avec ce gel du coup du
classement est ce que vous pensez qu'ils
auraient pu être dans le top 4 ou un top
100 mondial grégory en tout cas il a eu
des performances qui aurait pu lui faire
accéder à ce top 100 maintenant la
question je pense qu'on ne pourra jamais
vraiment se positionner tu aies jamais
il répond parce que le système actuel
est bien lui empêche d'accéder à ce
classement en tout cas lui il en est
persuadé le dire dans les propos qu'il a
tenus au journal l'équipe aujourd'hui
pour être dans les 80 premiers mondiaux
s'il n'y avait pas eu ce gel est ce
dégel progressif parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y aura gel
il faut aussi préciser que le dégel est
plutôt progressif en prenant en compte
et effectivement les allées les les les
performances sur les tournois de mars à
août 2010 neuf en tout cas lui en est
convaincu donc j'ai envie de lui laisser
effectivement oui on pourrait croire
qu'ils puissent être dans ce top son jeu
j'ai envie d'y croire
allez-y gens il se reconnecte il est il
est figé pour l'instant mais je le
rappelle il est sur la route le théâtre
au péage on sait pas trop ce qui se
passe mais en tout cas on compte qu'ils
se reconnecte dans quelques instants
c'est à vous gens oui je disais est ce
que est ce que greg grève ils viennent
de dire que finalement les résultats
qu'il a obtenus arthur pourront être
pris en compte dans un peu plus tard non
puisque justement en fait le classement
atp est calculée sur les 52 semaines
précédentes sur l'année finalement en
cours d'année sur l'autre d'une année
sur l'autre donc là c'est effectivement
les points de 2019 qui on est et on va
dire acquis entre mars et août 2019 qui
se sont pris en compte mais non
a pas de ce système là normalement n'est
pas voué à continuer il prendra fin en
août prochain donc non il ne profitera
pas des quelques résultats et des très
bons résultats qu'il a obtenus
très récemment et notamment une victoire
à istanbul ce n'est pas normal ce n'est
pas normal pour vous alors mais non mais
non non non pas normal il jouit gagne il
aurait aidé il doit le mot de la fin sur
cette thématique on espérait retrouver
pierre pierre est en train de se
reconnecter il vient de m'envoyer un
message on espère le retrouver dans dans
quelques instants on va passer
maintenant notre page découverte
on va maintenant par les danses
anastasia ponomareva originaire
d'ekaterinburg en russie est une
championne de danse sportive
une discipline qui englobe des danses
américaine et des danses de salon
installé depuis l'été dernier à
versailles cet athlète a découvert cette
discipline à l'âge de 6 ans dans son
pays natal
on écoute je n'avais pas beaucoup de
choix parce que j'ai un grand fair qui
est dense et seniors aussi les danses
sportives en russie et puis quand ma
mère a mené mon frère pour prendre des
cours de danse dans une école de danse
il m'a amené aussi avec eux du coup
j'étais à côté de la piste de danse j'ai
écouté de la musique j'essayais de me
bouger un peu et puis un jour ma mère
m'a dit garcia sait être maintenant à
l'est ou en russie et la danseuse se
fait un nom elle termine notamment 7e
sur 400 couples lors de la finale du
championnat national
à 19 ans la sportive d'un mètre 60 15
décide de venir en france pour
collaborer avec le français sml texier
le duo s'entraîne quotidiennement et
remporte plusieurs compétitions
nationales dont la coupe de france à
mulhouse en 2018
je me sens bien plaisir
je suis heureuse d'être là et
et avec cette ambiance merveilleuse des
lumières des la public qui vote pour toi
qui te ce port c'était extraordinaire et
puis à la fin quand ils ont dit que j'en
ai les premières c'était vous
aujourd'hui à 23 ans nastasia fait
partie de l'équipe de france de danse
sportive l'un de ses plus grands rêves
remporter un jour le championnat de
france pour cela la jeune russe est à la
recherche d'un nouveau partenaire de
danse ans le message est passé à 1 gens
si vous voulez alors la question sur ce
thème la danse sportive est elle un vrai
sport oui ou non
alors on n'a toujours pas récupéré
pierre on espère toujours récupérer il
était trop péage comme le comme je
disais oh oui manila qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous pour vous aussi
alors est ce que la danse sportive est
un vrai sport également manila je vous
donnais à la parole oui je pense que
c'est un vrai sport je pense qu'il sait
c'est bien la danse est dit la danse
classique danse sportive
j'adore ce parti oui bien sûr je pense
qu'à ses saints c'est un peu simple spa
genre qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
alors voilà vous avez candidate est en
tout cas pour être le prochain
partenaire de l'est de danse moi qui ai
pratiqué pendant de nombreuses années
je peux vous dire que c'est très très
sportif
les traits physiques et il faut quand
même une belle parade pour pratiquer
cette discipline
grégory j'ai envie de vous dire la
réponse est un peu dans votre question
est ce que la danse sportive et elle
voit là et elle un sport donc oui j'ai
envie de vous dire oui pour être plus
sérieux effectivement dans la danse cij
élargi le sujet à la danse y ait une
dimension culturelle artistique
mais il ya bien évidemment une dimension
sportive il faut pas oublier que la
fédération française de danse est
affiliée au ministère des sports donc ça
c'est déjà aussi un premier élément de
réponse
les danseurs les danseuses quand on les
regarde ce sont des vrais athlètes
michael vous et moi on aimerait quand
même ressemblé en avoir le physique des
danseurs à ses vrais des vrais golgoth
ils sont ils sont quand même bien bâti
ils ont ils ont vraiment des physique
d'athlète pour le coup d'ailleurs si on
regarde aussi quand il ya des blessures
ça s'apparente quand même
aux blessures qui peuvent aussi
intervenir dans le monde du sport et
puis toujours sur cette thématique de la
danse sont les largesses que la danse
est elle un sport regarder sur les
prochains gio il y aura du hip hop le
hip hop c'est une danse donc c'est aussi
montrer que de plus en plus c'est bien
la danse est considéré comme un sport
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya pas de
disciplines danse aux jo mais c'est
quand même un premier pas au moins qu'on
aura on aura ces sept 7 disciplines du
hip hop audio donc oui oui pour moi là
dedans sportif c'est complètement soir
je rappelle que cette danse sportive
englobe le style américain de danse
comme l'américan smooth l'américaine
rythme le rock and roll le boogie woogie
le breakdance le disco et le hip hop
voilà c'est en gros du patinage
artistique c'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit
mais sur la glace et son épatant en vo
et le patinage artistique et audio aux
jo d'hiver
bon voilà ce n'est pas encore en géo
mais pourquoi pas pierre chevallier on
l'a récupéré
pierre chevallier alors on a cru vous
perdre vous à retrouver ben oui mais je
suis passé dans un trou noir de réseaux
là alors valeurs morales de danse je
sais pas si j'ai joué avec andry je vois
qu'on parle de sport intéressant et ça
voilà le don est ce que la danse
sportive est un vrai sport oui ou non
non là je pense honnêtement je dirais
non mais je mais je n'ai pas vu les
belles images et à mon avis vous voit
une certaine forme de dépenses on peut
les prêts en régie éventuellement ces
images pour permettre à pierre de se
faire une idée
voilà comme vous pouvez le voir non là
non les modifie que c'était en mix entre
le patinage artistique est là et la
danse artistique ont mis sur la glace et
l'épatant c'est ce que je disais la tête
je pense que cette qu'elle ce genre de
questions là c'est on l'est on les a
souvent et je dirais spontanément n'ont
pas forcément en sport disciplines
artistiques
est-ce que ça mérite d'aller aux jo new
non manila peut-être moi je donne la
parole à mme ndiaye après je vous
redonne la parole pierre je pense qu'il
faut qu'elle fasse ce sport fasse un peu
ses preuves je pense que je pense que
cela est vraiment très connu aussi une
petite soeur hege aux signes pour ceux
qui ont essayé plusieurs pratiquants à
pau pourrait passer je pense mais ceci
dit en termes de discipline en termes de
discipline préparation physique et ses
terres à l'entraînement il ya plein de
choses arrivent c'est surya
c'est peu mais ça peut ça peut passer
mais ici a eu le pied
poutine une grande majorité des
pratiquants du chevalier
je dirais un bleu brille tant sportives
comme le bret comme le breakdance dont
on a souvent parlé aussi sur ce plateau
je pense qu'il ya suffisamment de sport
et de disciplines sportives pour laisser
le les disciplines artistiques à la et
pour le coup de laisser l'olympisme
vraiment à des confrontations sportives
avec une vraie non pas qu'elle soit
fausse mais une vraie dimension sportive
[Applaudissements]
alors on va passer à notre dernière
thématique on va parler de pilates
qu'est ce que c'est grégory le pilates
alors là je rappelle que c'est un petit
peu une blague entre nous parce qu'à
chaque fois on veut passer le pilates et
ça ne passe pas et aujourd'hui ça va
passer alors grégory
qu'est ce que le pilat à un petit peu
d'histoire pour commencer c'est un sport
qui a été inventé au début du 20e siècle
aux états unis par un gymnaste allemand
son nom joseph pilates est donc déjà
vous allez aussi l'origine historique
l'origine du nom pilates s pilates le
pilote c'est à l'origine méthode de
rééducation pour les danseurs
professionnels où l'on parlait de danse
il ya un instant et si une discipline
qui a été élargi et qui est aujourd'hui
accessible à tous elle est notamment
pratiqué par une association qui est
basée à montigny le bretonneux
le pilote c'est en fait une gymnastique
de renforcement des muscles profonds
principalement au niveau de la ceinture
abdominale et du dos et cela permet de
corriger sa posture de gagner en force
et en souplesse
mais plus qu'une simple rééducation le
pilote peut être aussi pratiqué à côté
d'une autre activité sportive pour se
ressourcer
alors on écoute justement les
responsables de cette activité au studio
et céline à montigny le bretonneux
le pilates c'est une gymnastique de
renforcement des muscles profonds dont
principalement au niveau de la sangle
abdominale et du dos donc c'est à une
gymnastique qui permet de travailler son
renforcement profond sa posture et de
gagner en force et en souplesse
il faut aussi avoir conscience que le
pilates c'est une gymnastique de
rééducation où on peut vraiment aider
tous les corps
dans tous les états possibles a continué
de se remuscler et à aller mieux alors
je rappelle évidemment que ces images
ont été tournées il y a quelques mois
dans ce studio céline est pas en ce
moment même alors ça fait travailler le
corps vous aviez raison grégory on
écoute justement les réactions à des
participants dans le pilate il ya
certains grands principes peuvent le
contrôler la respiration mais aussi le
rythme tant au point de vue musculaire
que cardiaque puisque on a comme vous
avez pu le voir on a attrapé une bonne
série on a bien soufflé alors très
rapidement je fais un petit tour de
table si je peux dire quel est votre
avis sur cette discipline ce sport du
coup le pilates gens vous êtes un grand
un adepte du du pilates un possible on
va tout faire mais non mais le pilote
forcément pour faire un carré je pense
que c'est un fait connu au niveau
musculaire douceur musculation douce et
comment elle coco maladie la propre
couple est ça ça doit être sympa ouais
moi pour moi je dis ok dit ok manila
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est fini le petit matin j'en ai jamais
fait mais en tout cas ça a l'air pas mal
ça apporte le sait qu'on peut le faire
en plus de notre activité sportive par
exemple moi je fais du gol je sais c'est
vraiment bien pour le travail et les
articulations la souplesse et
élémentaire c'est d'ailleurs ce vallier
moi je suis tout perturbé j'avais jamais
préparé toutes les notes depuis déjà
vingt émissions et là bon là je les ai
pas sous la main je suis à la fois ému
aussi depuis que de pouvoir en parler
enfin mais plus sérieusement je dirais
que c'est une ça fait partie de ces
disciplines douce qui sont peu
traumatique est au contraire très très
vertueuse pour le pour que un maximum de
personnes hommes et femmes surtout les
femmes pour le pilote je crois mes
hommes et femmes puissent pratiquer une
activité sportive et qui est laid
bénéfique pour les muscles profonds et
le bien-être en général donc comme jean
positif et peut-être futurs pratiquants
rapidement grégory ce que vous pourriez
pratiquer cette discipline
mais pourquoi pas ce qui a été
intéressant et qui a été dit c'est que
c'est une discipline vraiment qui est
accessible à tous et en plus de ça même
sans pratiquer un autre sport à côté moi
le football ça peut permettre
effectivement de de faire un petit peu
de musculation profond voilà c'est ça
peut être une idée intéressante pour on
va dire a ajouté ça un autre sport
pourquoi pas le faire avec jean pour
vous réconcilier avec son duel épique
que vous avez eue dans cette émission on
s'aime bien alors c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
je vous propose mes citations du très
regretté le génie diego armando à
maradona
ma mère pense que je suis le meilleur et
j'ai été élevé en croyant toujours en ce
que ma mère me disait je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui